good morning Hank it's Tuesday so we're
undergoing a pretty significant office
reorganization project and along the way
I found a number of documents from my
past like this old picture of me good
news little me your prices are gonna
come off in six more years I also found
this somewhat newer picture of me I'm
not sure if this is a photograph but
it's definitely realistic and from 2006
my favorite fan mail ever in regards to
Looking for Alaska I can honestly say
that after putting your book down I felt
a feeling that I had not felt before it
was not a sickness like I was going to
throw up or a feeling like I had to take
a crap or anything but I felt something
your book made me feel something man not
the two major things I feel the urges to
defecate and vomit but something new and
Hank I also found from way back in 1994
some of my report cards this is from my
junior year of high school Hank I got a
c-minus in Latin John went into a
tailspin in this course during the last
six weeks he missed too many classes and
seldom was prepared for the daily lesson
yeah that's bad that's a dead language
this is from my French got a b-minus in
French not to brag it's safe to say that
John under achieved this year of
American history I got a B John managed
to get to class more often during the
final trimester and his grade came up a
bit and those necessary to say AB it
could have just ended it at my grade
came up technically accurate I got a
c-minus in pre-k which frankly was
probably generous chemistry C and in
English I got a c-minus incredible
potential as an English student but he's
reached a juncture where he just can't
mail it in anymore Hank I don't talk
much about what a terrible student I was
in high school I think partly because
I'm still embarrassed about it 20 years
later I did miss a lot of classes you
know because they were early or because
they conflicted with my schedule of
smoking cigarettes in the woods but even
when I attended class I was still a
pretty terrible student Hank you know
you become the third best C student in
the entire state of Alabama at academic
decathlon first by getting terrible
grades so you're not an A or B student
and that's who I was in high school I
underachieved in a skipped classes and I
didn't do my homework and I didn't do
the reading and I was always behind and
stressed out meanwhile Linc you were
getting great grades and not smoking
cigarettes and then you'd get a
scholarship to college and everything
anyway coming across these report cards
made me think a couple things the first
is that I was incredibly
lucky like I didn't just get a second
chance I got hundreds of chances and
even though I was a crap student I still
had excellent teachers who continued to
believe in me despite my not giving them
a reason to the other thing these old
report cards made me think about Hank
was this high school is not destiny it's
part of life but I feel like when you're
in high school people act like it's the
most important thing you ever do and
like the whole course of your life is
being decided but at least so far as I
can tell the course of your life isn't
decided ever most of the time it's not
like there's like one fork in the road
and you choose one or you choose the
other there are hundreds of Forks in the
road every day that you're alive College
is also not destiny for the record I was
a much better college student than I was
a high school student also your 20s are
not destiny your 30s are not destiny
like destiny is not something that
happens all at once it's something that
happens only in retrospect hey when I
was in high school I thought I was just
kind of a screw-up you know but in the
end Hank people aren't just one thing
like I was a screw-up but I was also a
pretty good reader and looking at those
old report cards I just want to thank my
teachers for knowing that I wasn't just
a screw-up
even when I didn't know it Hank I'll see
you on Friday